[MUSIC PLAYING]
This episode was proudly
made possible by Subaru.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know, a lot of people
lose sleep every night
because they think the
world is going to hell
and that things
are getting worse.
And we have a mass media that
operates under the principles--
if it bleeds, it leads.
And you can understand
why that is the case.
I mean, we have inherited
an amygdala in our brain
which is the part
of the brain that's
responsible for triggering an
alarm during moment in which we
have to flee or neutralize
a perceived threat.
This has been
biologically selected
for because it has helped
us survive over time.
So you can understand why we
are glued to the TV screen
through the most negative
news and creating
a sort of
self-amplifying feedback
loop of doom and gloom.
But again, my friends,
look a little bit closer.
Peek behind the curtain.
And what you actually find
is a lot more reassuring.
According to the work
of Steven Pinker, who
wrote the book, "The Better
Angels of our Demons,"
and has a viral TED Talk called,
The Myth of Violence, the world
has actually been getting
better for hundreds of years.
Today-- according to
Pinker-- the chances
of a man dying at the hands of
another man on a global scale
are the lowest than they've ever
been in the history of mankind.
Listen to that again.
The chances of a man dying
at the hands of another man
are the lowest that
they've ever been.
Hans Rosling, a statistician
and data visualizer,
has gone viral with a series
of talks-- including a TED
Talk-- in which he maps
every nation on earth
by every measurable
indicator of quality of life
and shows that every
nation is improving.
Even the ones on
the very bottom are
doing better than
they used to be.
So again, when seen
as a whole, you
see the man-machine civilization
increasingly leveraging
its tools to address the
grand problems of humanity.
I mean, there was
an article recently
in The New York Times that
said that the most extreme form
of poverty around the world
is actually almost eliminated.
I mean, I would
have never known.
This was in The New York Times.
It's unbelievable.
Or a 2010 United Nations
Development essay
cited by Bill Clinton
and Time Magazine
in an article titled,
"A Case for Optimism,,"
in which he says-- forget
about the info-haves
and the info-nots.
And he cited the cell phone
as the greatest invention
in history to pull
people out of poverty.
So again, these are just the
numerous amount of examples.
There's infinitely more.
But the world is
on the right track.
It's not utopia, as
Steven Johnson would say,
but it's leaning that way.
And I'm not just saying that
because I'm an optimist.
These are data-driven facts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Be sure to check out
SecondChance Subaru
at revision3.com/subaru.
[MUSIC PLAYING]